hello and congratulations on the film
thank you thank you very much all right
so I'm going to apologize about my first
question because it's a big old career
question but I love hearing about how
someone's goals can evolve as this
industry evolves so what is something
about your priorities when choosing
roles that stayed the same since day one
but then also what's a new priority
that's emerged over the years
I've only only wanted to do stuff I'm
interested in and stuff that I thought
was interesting it doesn't necessarily
have to be interesting to other people
it only has to really interest me and
that's that's always been the same you
know so getting to do this was you know
was a gift because this was not my plan
it wasn't your plan how so well I had
not intended to be in it
so the producing came first in this case
yeah the producing and and at one point
I was going to act but it was years and
years and years ago so uh I by the time
we got it I've evolved into Grandma it
wasn't the same role when you first
considered acting in it
um yeah maybe till it's very
very much alive in the mind of the actor
she is she is
as extraordinary as you want her to be
as a mother so no that role was was
great
this
young woman's performance is
off the charts you know she just
it's this is her part do you know what I
mean this was this was for her you know
and when you see her it's just you just
your mouth hangs open
she's that good you know so I'm very
happy being a grandma I can confirm that
happened to me the entire film from top
to bottom Danielle's work is exceptional
here before I get to working with her
though just to go back to what you were
just saying what would you say is the
biggest difference between the script
when you first committed to producing
the project and what we see now in the
final film how has it evolved since
oh who can say I mean it's the story has
always been very crystal clear because
of course we had Keith who really is the
he's the bones of the project because
this is something that he's been part of
forever he made the documentary that
reopened the case he's this has been
something he's been trying to do and he
was trying to do it before Mrs Mobley
passed and unfortunately we weren't able
to we weren't able to get it done uh but
this relationship of
mother and son
was always a priority this was when when
Barbara broccoli and Fred solo and I and
Keith sat down this was the that was
always
the peace that we felt people needed to
get they needed to understand these are
normal people these are people who lived
in Chicago they like your grandmother
your cousin your uncle
um and when when uh tanoia came in as
director she said I really want to focus
on that relationship and we were like
great that's what we want do your thing
you know and then Orion was like what do
you want to do and we said this is what
we're doing they said do your thing and
so
everybody did their thing and
here it is sometimes the timing is meant
to be because I can't imagine the end
product being any stronger than what I
just saw the other day no no nor can I
nor can I I don't see what anyone could
have done it could only be what it is
you know oh absolutely all right so
let's talk about Danielle and also uh
chanoia because this is one heck of a
third feature film here and I just have
Mighty High Hopes that they're going to
be many many more feature films in her
future so what is something about the
way she works on set as an actors
director that you're really looking
forward to other actors experiencing on
her future films going forward
well I you know I I don't know how to
how to answer that because one one of
the things that for me is that's a lot
of pressure to put on people
and
I don't know that everyone everything
that you do can always be you know like
the last thing that you did I what I
wanted to what I want for her is I want
her to be as multi-dimensional as she
can be in what she does because I want
her to do this but I want to see if she
can do you know a western I want to see
if she can do a musical you know I wanna
I want her to to find the things that
she really digs and do them you know but
sometimes I think when people
say well I I want to see what she's
gonna it's like a challenge and that's a
lot of pressure and I find it I I feel
like this because people used to do this
to me all the time and say well you're
not as good in this as you were in the
other things but the other thing is
different it's not the same you know so
I'm I I look for a more widened
perspective I I definitely understand
that just because this is coming to mind
now it feels to me like you have done a
little bit of everything is there
anything kind of left on The Bucket List
in terms of you know I don't know what
type of role or a genre or anything that
you're really itching to do
oh yeah tons of stuff you know I still
want to do a horror movie I want to do a
western uh I you know I want to do a
silent movie I mean I want to do all
kinds of stuff yeah I love silent movies
I'm all for everything you just said but
let's prioritize the horror movie
I'd like to do that soon you know this
is my genre I like that answer
um let's talk a little bit about
Danielle because as we've already
established she is exceptional in this
film so what is it about her as a scene
not actually not only as a scene partner
but also as a leader being number one on
a call sheet that you really appreciated
while you're on set
well she knew her stuff and we could go
in and out you know we could do what we
needed to do and then to know to say cut
and then we could talk about you know
the shoes that she liked that I had on
at some point you know and then say you
know rolling and we're back in and that
to me is
is freeing
because everybody knows what they're
there to do and when someone is that
good it makes you better